[Music]
this is star talk sports edition
today
we're going to talk about
weed
yeah i said it marijuana and what effect
that has does should shouldn't have
in sports and i got gary o'reilly with
me gary hey neil all right all right uh
ex
ex football footballer
football as in soccer i guess yes round
ball round balls
and chuck chuck
yes always good to have you
yeah ex weed smoker
that's weed smoker and uh
and uh and current weed smokers
and futures
and future weed smokers so yeah okay
um
so what we've got here today is other
than chuck having been a former wheat
smoker and possibly future one we don't
have particular expertise in what role
any of this plays in athletic
competition so we
combed our
searched our rolodex and we came back to
uh one of our previous guests this it's
stacy gruber stacey welcome back to star
talk
thanks so much for having me yeah you're
one of the world's experts on what
marijuana does to the brain to our
thoughts to our decisions to our
abilities and let me just get your full
title here director of cognitive and
clinical neuro imaging
at the mclean hospital's brain imaging
center and your associate professor of
psychiatry at harvard medical school so
that's you sound you've got all the
right stuff here and your your research
includes
neurocognitive models and multimodal
brain imaging
and the best part here is you're
assessing risk factors of substance
abuse
and
farm in the psychopathology
of it all did i did i get that right you
left out one thing neil what uh
my hero
okay
the only thing i would tell you is we
started the mind program marijuana
investigations for neuroscientific
discovery or mind oh i see what you did
there very good
because there was really no data um
until very recently on the long-term
effects of cannabis when people use it
for medical purposes as opposed to
recreational organelles really important
distinction and factors into our talk
today for sure very excellent so we'll
get right to it many of us think about
cannabis as a recreational drug
and
with very little sort of side effects
to it from what's intended and also
medicinal use has been around for
millennia as i understand it
yeah thousands of years and so
uh let me ask you let's get straight
into this because this is star talk
sports edition and
shikari richardson's
olympic band all right she was the 100
meter sprinter
that
was tested positive for cannabis
and
i i have to and so she got
booted from the olympics she's not in
her key event in the olympics because
she tested positive cooking so i have to
ask and start off this this segment
in what way does smoking weed
increase your musculoskeletal reaction
time and make you run faster
is this
in what way does it enhance your
performance in the 100 meter dash
it's a fantastic question and i'll tell
you most people say things like hey if
you could smoke weed or use cannabis and
perform and win you should get something
for it because you're two metals
you should get two metals
right that's exactly right and to your
point you know
cannabis has been around for thousands
and thousands of years first documented
use was as medicine
you know and it was part of our
pharmacopia since 1850 we prescribed it
then it became illegal through a series
of events that i know chuck knows you're
not talking well i know it exactly right
they just let chuck out
out of jail
he just got out okay
the mid 90s saw us revisit this and
california was the first state to
legalize cannabis for medical purposes
but in terms of sports you know the
waterless the the world anti-doping
association um has cannabis on on the
list of prohibited substances and
you know there's been a lot about this
especially with regard to chicago
richardson and i think you have to meet
two of three criteria to be on that list
it poses risk to your athletes it
provides a performance health risk
health risk
but i think the i think that the
language is pretty open and vague that's
part of the concern here
okay i risk winning the sport okay
there's a risk for it
there you go and it violates the spirit
of the sport which is one of those
casual caveats that anything can fall
under but to your point
most studies to date document that one
does not have improved let's say or
faster reaction time or improved or
increased coordination quite the
opposite when we're talking about what
we think of as typical conventional
recreational or adult used cannabis
that's not what we see individual
constituents might confer some benefit
but when we're talking about
flower whole plant products typically
used for adult or recreational purposes
to change one's current state of being
we don't see improvements in reaction
time that's not what we see from a
research perspective and most of the
science that leads us back to where we
are now in terms of it being prohibited
is a little bit questionable and i think
a lot of people are now taking a much
closer look at exactly uh why it's on
the list
wow
so so
does this have anything to do i mean i
don't want to get into the whole history
of weed but you know and reefer madness
and why that happened and you know being
connected to madness the the public
service film right public service film
and going up before that is the
connection between
black people
and white people coming together
believe it or not that was the problem
forget all that 2020 i believe they
removed it from schedule one or i
i don't know if they actually removed it
or did they take a vote but i read about
it sometimes so can you tell me about
that and what is schedule one just what
is on the same page
so
just a real quick history thing again to
your point it was part of our
pharmacopia reefer madness really refers
to a period of time in which the the
nation really fell under this spell and
there are a lot of psychosocial reasons
that this happened we won't get into it
but it fell out of favor the marijuana
made cannabis illegal and it not only
was removed from the pharmacopeia which
doctors used to prescribe not recommend
or suggest prescribed um it became pla
it became illegal in the 1970 controlled
substance act that was placed in the
most restrictive class schedule one
schedule one which by definition
gentlemen no accepted medical value okay
that's where cannabis sits today chuck
to your point but sitting sitting right
next to other drugs like what cocaine
heroin no cocaine schedule two sir okay
did i ask you the
question i don't know i was just
thinking about cocaine
i'm not going to go there that's fine
okay so schedule one which who's to its
left and who's to his right in schedule
one
so um
cannabis sits in schedule one alongside
things like heroin lsd so no accepted
medical value which people have of
course begun to question because
individual constituents from the plant
this plant is complicated there's over
400 compounds 100 of these interact with
our brain and body system of chemicals
and receptors the question is if there's
no accepted medical value how is it that
you have an fda approved medication like
epidialex a single extracted purified
compound for kids with pediatric onset
seizure disorders that's not only fda
approved but you know not in schedule
one so schedule one by definition most
restrictive class and to your point
chuck cannabis remains illegal at the
federal level in 2018 you're thinking of
the hemp act 28
the hemp act was passed which basically
said that all cultivars or chemo bars
all plants basically of cannabis sativa
l
that had less than 0.3 percent thc
the primary uh intoxicating constituent
of the plant is what gets you high it's
what our recreational adult users are
typically looking for every plant that
had less than 0.3 percent thc by weight
was okay it's industrial hemp so it's a
really interesting shift that we've had
because
this is the proliferation that we've
seen of cbd high products products high
in cbd that may or may not have thc up
to a certain point the ioc which banned
um
shikari richardson where are they
getting their
information from are they getting it
from who's a wada
what is the the acronym i think it's the
world anti-doping association yes you
think well well damp world anti-doping
are they getting their their insights
from the world anti-doping association
and are they getting it from outdated
federal legislation i mean who's who's
mine in the store here
not another really great question so the
question is where does this science
where does the sort of evidence for this
come from and most people are turning
back to some some studies that happened
in a review paper that was published in
2011 i think and they lean into it
pretty hard and that was enough evidence
to sort of maintain its current status
whether or not it should remain there is
something different again i would say
this if we know that people who let's
just think of people who smoke or vape
cannabis for for fun or recreational
purposes
is their reaction time faster no
more
no okay so
take that first do they even want to run
in the race no
is there a competition where you can sit
on the couch and eat donuts
not everybody not everybody uses the
same types of products right and so so
here's the here's the big distinction so
when people think of things like that
um and they ask the question should this
or should this not be prohibited is it
performance enhancing actually from that
perspective no but some people have
raised the following question well it
relaxes people it allows you to let
things go it's great for anxiety again
very low doses of thc good for anxiety
uh higher doses not so much don't go
there other constituents are great for
that too but if that's the case if it's
an indirect effect that we're seeing
it's not the same as a steroid which
allows you to build muscle significantly
faster and with less effort right with
an elite athlete and we kind of bounce
back into the shikari richardson
scenario here
what difference would there be for them
to consume thc as opposed to cbd and i
know each and individual athletes will
react differently i appreciate that much
but in a broad stroke could you explain
that to us doctor and just to be clear
thc is
tetrahydrocannabis is that what that
stands for stands for delta nine
tetrahydrocannabinol and industrial
primary intoxicating constituent of the
plant again lots of players here the
other big player yeah
the other big player here that people
have spent a lot of time and attention
on is cannabidiol or cbd a primary
non-intoxicating constituent of the
plant often touted for its
therapeutic potential so when we think
about what could happen if you
are exposed to large amounts of thc
versus cbd what you typically find is
cbd again is not intoxicating people use
it for all sorts of reasons there is
very scant evidence here from a
scientific perspective you know as a
neuroscientist we we like to have
empirically sound data evidence matters
evidence matters man exactly and here
policy is outpaced sign so we want to be
very clear about what these
constituents do and don't do and we
don't know the whole thing yet we really
don't it's a complex story especially
when we start thinking about
multi-compound products not just thc or
just cbd but the ways in which people
typically use right right um like
shikari richardson so to your point gary
what what do we expect again products
that are higher in thc typically are
used for those who are looking for
from a recreational perspective looking
to change their current state of being
or sort of take themselves out of
something cbd is not intoxicating would
you find that somebody has any
physiologic change after using cbd there
have been some preclinical studies
suggesting that um and there's some
human studies suggesting it but the
evidence is pretty pretty sparse we have
to do a lot more work in this area all
right listen when we come back uh after
this break this short break uh what we
really want to get to the bottom of is
how is it that these chemicals that all
extracted from weed can be banned or not
banned yet there's all manner of other
chemicals that we take that do influence
us physiologically that just get
completely overlooked like for example
ibuprofen to get rid of pain or or even
coffee so when we come back we're going
to see
how does everything else we do and
ingest
measure up to cannabis on star talk
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about cannabis marijuana
and what role it can play has played
should or shouldn't play
in athletic competition and we've got dr
stacy gruber
not her first rodeo with us here on star
talk uh this time we're just really
trying to find out what's going on in
the olympics uh how is it that uh
shakari richardson got banned and but
more importantly for this segment stacy
i want to know
how is it that i can take sort of a
non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drug
and said
yep
and said okay that you've got an acronym
for that non-steroid anti-inflammatory
to end sayed
and said
and the olympics and and they'll find
that in my pee or however they measure
it and all is fine
okay but if i took a
cannabinoid
that's bad
don't they have similar effects on our
bodies and what's going on there
so you know they really um
again these rules these regulations
these guidelines i think are set in
place sometimes in the absence of
clear evidence and in the case of an
nsaid which is very clearly used as an
analgesic or a pain reliever which also
helps with inflammation um these are
actually two things that people often
use cannabis for you happen to raise a
really good point and sets are legal and
they are not
again you know sort of on the illicit
substance uh they're not in the control
substance group and they're not in the
csa at all so
could someone make an argument that
adsense could themselves be performance
enhancing because they help reduce
inflammation or help with pain sure
cannabis or marijuana i think is is
prohibited uh for a number of reasons
and they did change the amount of
cannabis quote it's actually a
metabolite of thc that's detected in the
urine they raise the limit of detection
from i think 15 nanograms to 150 because
people are using whole plant
full-spectrum products that are
primarily comprised of cbd and other
non-intoxic constituents
um but you may still test positive for
thc so nanogram that's a billionth of a
gram
nanogram
personal astrophysicist who knows the
lexicon did i hear that right that's oh
my gosh okay
that means they're really getting into
your pee
i'm just saying if they know
nanogram contents in my pee
in a bottle first
okay
so doctor right so here i am i've gone
into the lab and i'm being creative and
i come up with a drug that's a a
stimulant
b
if i test it on mice could be proven to
improve muscle growth
and if i mix it with water
it's rich in antioxidants
would water ban this truck
great question
again the world anti-doping so agency
yeah it's a great question i'm not sure
what criteria they use because okay what
if i called it coffee
you know i could make the same argument
for so many things it's again i have a
feeling and i could be wrong because i
don't live in the water sort of bubble
or or
the international olympic committee but
i i have a feeling this has a lot to do
with the fact that cannabis remains
schedule one at the federal level that's
what i was wondering because if somebody
thinks it's bad then you don't want to
be the one who says it's not bad right
maybe that they're afraid to be the
first out of the gate on that and i
think that there have been some uh some
studies that have uh perhaps uh
prematurely or perhaps without a huge
amount of evidence behind it decided
that it can in fact help people with
their performance so therefore it must
be a performance enhancing substance
that has really come under a fair amount
of scrutiny these days and again when
you do a comparison between cannabis and
other substances like alcohol alcohol is
not on the banned list right
so i got one it sounds to me like water
really should be what are you talking
about
what are you what are you out of your
mind like that's
that kind of is what water is
that's not
it's
so doctor we we kind of
immediately default to
an impairment of cognitive skills on on
using cannabis or or marijuana
but are there and i do believe the term
that you use is downstream
effects of
cannabis use that could be seen as
an a2 performance performance not being
i run faster jump higher but in recovery
i maybe ate sleep have an
anti-inflammatory property do we have
those downstream effects from
this drug yeah and why not ban sleep
because getting sleep enhances your
performance it's the best thing you can
do for your performance you actually
across the board almost for anything you
know right so we should ban it because
it enhances performance i think i think
to your point again there's a difference
between direct and indirect effects and
how do you start to measure
what will or won't have an effect uh you
know downstream so some of these
constituents have certainly been shown
to be anti-inflammatory and help promote
sleep help reduce anxiety could those
you know at some level help someone
function day-to-day remember that
athletic performance is also an
extension of how that individual is in a
given date this young lady was quite
brave and quite open and honest and told
the world why she used it and i think
most people had a rather visceral
response like ah i get that she also
knew what the stated sort of guidelines
were and did it anyway the point is um
who's to say what is and isn't going to
have a downstream effect we know that
exposure to cannabis or certain
cannabinoids when an individual is very
young can result in some decrements
absolutely true sure that's not
necessarily the case for individuals as
they get older and we've had some
evidence to come to sort of contradict
what we've seen in the recreational
consumers but again the story is pretty
um it's pretty unclear here well how
about how about this there's some people
as we know who have sort of genetic
um
inability to process alcohol yes in ways
that others do is there are there
genetic variations in people's reactions
to the cannibinoids or whatever yes
absolutely
and can i can i just dovetail on neil's
question can you as you answered that
tell us about cannabinoid receptors in
our brain because i've read somewhere
that it's the only so-called drug the
thc being the psychoactive constituent
uh it's the only drug that actually our
brain is already designed to latch on to
that i heard that too i heard that
people say i'm wired for weed quick
primer you have cb1 and cb2 receptors
they're part of the endocannabinoid
system a system of chemicals and
receptors throughout the brain and the
body thc binds pretty effectively to cb1
receptors for example we also have
things like mu and kappa receptors that
are
again are endogenous but they um are the
targets for opioids so you know it's not
just cannabis
okay but to your point um the cytochrome
p450 enzyme system in your liver
basically dictates how you process
things and and again really great point
genetically we are not all created
equally we're just not and there are
some groups that don't process alcohol
right uh some cultures ashkenazi jews
for example we don't have a ton of
alcohol dehydrogenase the thing that
breaks down alcohol and allows us to
process it effectively so there are many
people who are poor metabolizers of thc
and as a result
they are often very very high for a very
long time these are the people here that
say things like oh my god i was you know
i i was out of my mind for for 12 to 14
hours
there are other people who metabolize so
effectively and so efficiently they can
have 30 40 50 milligrams of a product
and these edibles and they don't show an
effect
so we are not all created equally and
your genetic
profile your makeup actually really will
dictate how you process these products
but i look at your your list of three
criteria right does it or was it the
ioc's criteria does it have the
potential to enhance
water what
new york city
w-a-t-e-r is pronounced water so that's
i can't it's hard for me to have this
conversation w-a-d-a water with water
give me a i need a cup of water yeah
give me water
it's a very new york city accent but so
these three criteria does it have the
potential to enhance performance is
there a health risk and does it violate
the spirit of the sport and i think
coffee
you can put a check in all three of
those boxes for coffee
and so so
marijuana and other drugs
also apparently but they're outlawed
yeah
it's a huge disparity i think and and
one that people are really looking at
much more closely now and again i think
you know the other things you have to
have two of the three criteria um one is
it violates the spirit of the sport one
is it poses risk to the athlete and
three i mean not in this order it
enhances athletic performance the spirit
of the sport is i want to be as best as
i possibly can be that's the spirit of
this faster higher stronger that's the
whole freaking point yeah it's the
mantra that get me started on this
i thought the spirit of the sport was i
don't care if i win or lose if i smoke
this
it's a new thing
that's the new olympic motto
i'ma smoke this weed not give a damn no
here's what you do no you put a couch
instead of that that flying cat that
rolling camera along the hundred meters
and you sit on the couch and watch other
people
different kind of olympics
stacy before we we take a break what
about the sports
where you can't be excited and pent up
for it because you need the stability of
precision
such as in the pistol shooting or in
archery
can we say that cannabis enhances your
performance because it settles your
physiology in a way that doesn't make
you nervous and then miss your target i
would actually take the opposite
perspective which is that cannabis isn't
one thing and it doesn't have one effect
for all people right some chemo bars or
cultivars or products are actually in
some ways stimulating for people and
they feel more energized they feel
you've the term is euphoric i you know i
want to make i want to do i want to i
think we talked about this once before
so that wouldn't necessarily uh you know
sort of support the point of settling it
would actually sort of go against when
people feel really blah or down they
often use a little cannabis that might
be
a product or a strain or chemovar that
influences or increases their energy so
that would argue against that not all
products are the same not all people are
the same and the ways that you use these
products absolutely dictates the outcome
okay so the takeaway is
weed
is highly chemically complex and you
can't generalize its effects
as a product without thinking more
precisely about the
the biochemistry of each of the
molecules that's exactly right it's not
one thing and it shouldn't be one size
does not fit all here yeah but but to my
point
if there's some sports where you need to
be calm
relative to other sports where you need
to be up
this same drug
could help you in one and harm you in
another your performance
i think that would be true across
multiple classes yes okay
okay so
enhanced performance doesn't always mean
uh faster higher stronger it can mean
more laid back
right again direct versus indirect
effects right exactly we got to take a
quick break but when we come back more
with stacy gruber our marijuana expert
up at the harvard medical school and
we're going to see what the future of
sports legislation looks like in the
face of new science or not on star talk
we're back
third and final segment for star talk
sports edition
all about marijuana in sports and of
course we can't do this without the
singular expert out there who thinks
about this who measures people's brains
who has all the fluency necessary to
settle these arguments uh dr stacy
gruber again welcome back stacy and
continuing our deep dive into this
uh what is going to happen with the
future of sports legislation in the face
of your research or more broadly
research into the chemistry that might
help us perform but if not it might help
us recover from injury for having
attempted to perform great question and
i wish i knew more about how these
agencies made their decisions um in
terms of the scientific literature it is
constantly evolving every day we have
new reports right on uh different
constituents or or different approaches
uh to addressing different symptoms or
conditions using cannabis for medical
purposes how does that dovetail with our
our elite athletes and what they may or
may not be using it for should there be
a distinction
in terms of what they're using and how i
think a lot of people are very
interested in this and for good reason
it's important to be up to date and to
let science guide the policies to allow
people to live the way that they live
and to understand
if certain things are very comparable
it's really difficult for people to
understand why one thing would be banned
and another would not
is is there a comprehensive study that's
done or being done that lets us know
exactly how cannabis will affect us
i think there are lots of different
studies that are currently underway that
look at different aspects but part of
the problem is that cannabis remains
illegal at the federal level so doing
research depending on the type of
research questions you want to ask is
not as easy as you think and what we're
talking about anything that is a
cannabis chemo bar cultivar and its
effect on whether it's athletic
performance or all sorts of things
there's stuff that we know and there's
an awful lot that we don't know the
question will be where does the
intersection of some kind of benefit
versus some kind of performance
enhancement get made i think that's a
bigger question
in 2020 neil the nfl the nba major
league baseball and hockey
all said no suspension if you test
positive for cannabis out of season now
in season they said you get a fine
now they obviously
have moved away from the wada cannabi
cannabinoids bad not happening you're
banned so they must be using some kind
of research some kind of somebody's
plugged into them yes yes somebody's we
are at an elite professional level
saying
that's cool
but you know if you we're going to stick
you on the naughty step with a big fine
but with wada it's an outright ban so
there seems to be a lag
between what's happening here in the u.s
and globally for wilder and i think
there might be a reason but i'd like to
hear what the doctor's thinking is and
if it's nfl nba mlb and nfl that's the
whole kit and the caboodle right there
especially the caboodle it's all in
there
you know i think it's a great point and
i think that again there is a
sort of a philosophy and an approach to
this remember that cannabidiol or cbd is
is not prohibited but they changed the
lower limit of detection from i think it
was 15 nanograms per ml to 150 for
exactly this reason i believe to make
sure that they were only looking for
what they considered current use as in
right before competition how that gets
determined uh you know is is a pretty
slippery slope i think um and to your
point gary it's a very very important
distinction when we talk about global
versus more local decisions that are
being made here in the united states
absolutely but and and so i would say
though no
i might i might um
conjecture that part of this is due to
the fact that we have decriminalized
marijuana on a state level pretty much
everywhere not to mention the however
many teen i don't know if it's 13 or 19
the last i checked states that say yo
man you can go ahead and do this so i
think the removing uh is not what the
legislation says
i think when you strip it from the penal
code
that
um you you allow you know people to say
okay and and you allow sports um
organizations to say hey you know
if this is not illegal if it is not like
a class felony or whatever it was it's
not criminal then why who are we to say
like you can't do it right so which
really should be happening here at the
risk of
being captain obvious
is
governmental legislation should actually
lead the scientific
enlightenment on this and then let the
official
sports organizations follow if you're
going to have sports organizations
allowing it but in principle they could
have allowed it decades ago right uh if
if the science was there stacy if
municipal federal legislation
is at the core of this that everyone
then reacts to what access do you have
to the writing of laws and and members
of congress and shouldn't you be
should you have a seat at the table
there you know i think a lot of us are
trying to have a seat and i don't know
that that's really the only pivotal
point here i think there are multiple
points that are critical um you know i
think when you are involved in the
conversation you have a better chance of
seeing things done comprehensively in a
way that is centrist that makes sense
that isn't motivated by other you know
let's just say um agenda items i think
it's very very important it's important
to have
emphasis on centrist right i mean
there's a point where you can land that
is scientifically reasonable and
sensible yeah it's you know let science
be your guide there is truth in science
right we know that and not everybody
believes that but i think there is truth
in science and if you allow science and
you don't think there is you know there
is and we all know there is
if you allow you don't have to have soft
vocabulary on this show
okay if you allow the science thank you
to to take its place and to and allow
the decisions to be based on evidence
and not
rhetoric or uh other things politics
it's i think it's a different it's a
different landscape it's a terribly
difficult landscape to navigate with
regard to cannabis in this country and
across the globe but especially in this
country with the discord between federal
and state regulations and it's created a
lot of confusion if we think the problem
lies with wada
not water wada
world anti-doping agency the clue may be
in the first of those words world
because as chuck's highlighted
cannabis is pretty legal in just about
every state
but world
hasn't all come to that conclusion yet
there are countries around the world
where marijuana is illegal and so they
have a problem that is so multifaceted
they are not probably able to solve it
so they have to be able to move because
they are international they need some
sensitive international sensitivities
they can't all be
in stacy's lab that's what we're saying
well that's a very good point gary i
didn't even consider that so i have the
answer we must get the leaders of that
country high
[Laughter]
council i will be there
what's up y'all and out
man
the next u.n general meeting is going to
be held in a park across the street
wait wait if you got them all high
that would end all war to be more solved
by that instead of things like a g20
summit you could ask for an og 20
something oh nice and it wouldn't be oh
g20 it'd be og 420
that's right we just solved world peace
damn
people need to get on board for sure and
at least come together and review what
we know what we don't know and then
whatever we don't know we should address
specific empirically sound research
studies to help clarify because stacy i
say this because i've been invited to
various committees and commissions that
serve washington interests and because i
have expertise that they value and so
it's not a weird thing for someone with
expertise to be brought in to the into
the room and so i'm going to vote i'm
going to vote you into congress how
about that
it'll be on the weed ticket
um i have i have testified
at congress previously and i
very um
uh i very often contributed and i
continue to do that in lots of different
ways i'm happy to continue that and
you're right so forgive me for even
thinking that had not already happened
to your point to your point we really
need a little bit more science and a
little less
rhetoric to help guide the discussions
both in this country and across the
globe well i think chuck solved that
that's right so i think part of the
problem is
regardless of what congress does they're
influential politicians who might think
one way or another about it and they
have their followers who just do what
they say right even our president
actually even our president who i think
has done a great job in shepherding us
through this covid crisis thinking about
the science thinking about the science
he's let the science lead him he is
adamantly opposed to marijuana being
decriminalized on a federal level
because he's the reefer madness
generation yeah that's why yeah
that's why
i just love the term reefer madness
so are we are we still in the wake
of the war on drugs
and we're we're waiting to get out of
that wash to find because that has
that's sp that spills into sports
decisions into sports committees yes i
think there i think a lot of folks again
are taking a much closer look these days
but again
there is the office of national drug
control policy and you know
the ideas and
sort of scientific evidence that allow
people to make good sound decisions
needs to be up to date and it needs to
be read
and understood what a concept
yeah tell me about it yeah wow
can we just do this
can't we just extend that to everything
that we do
just everything that we do let me let me
ask this though because i know we're
running short until we're running really
short i know we're really really sure um
i have seen people get very upset and
heated in this debate and they talk
about the fact that marijuana is indeed
addictive and the reason why it should
not be allowed for use or it's a gateway
as a gateway right because that you can
you can become addicted to it and and
that it is indeed a gateway and all of
those things those tropes that we've
heard can you just talk about it i don't
i don't care if it's true or not just
what are you from a scientific
what does that mean chuck i mean answer
whether or not it's true what the hell
kind of what's a giant essay type
question i don't care whether it's true
or not but can you talk about it
really quickly um to schools of thought
is cannabis or marijuana addictive there
are certainly people who wind up with
what we call cannabis use disorder in
the old days we would call it uh abuse
versus dependence now we have a new term
cannabis use disorder
and the numbers of individuals who use
cannabis who wind up with cannabis use
disorder vary depending on the study
that you're looking at
and it's really important to keep in
mind that you have to actually
meet the people who are using the
cannabis and toxic about their use as
opposed to just assuming that because
they use daily they must have a use
disorder first and foremost number two
gateway phenomena gateway hypothesis
gateway theory the use of cannabis will
obviously lead to the use of harder
drugs because people who use cannabis
where people use heroin often used
cannabis first that doesn't mean that
the use of cannabis led to heroin use in
terms of the receptors in your brain
again these things get turned on
in terms of exposure to certain
substances like drugs or sugar or sex or
all sorts of things so the gateway
hypothesis is one that i think most
people have sort of let go of at this
point
there's not really great evidence
suggesting that one leads to another is
there an overlap and those who use um
heart let's say quote harder drugs who
have used cannabis sure and why is that
usually that's um more a factor of their
sort of psychosocial experiences and
people who are or just practicality you
know if my my first drug is probably not
going to be heroin okay it's going to be
some other drug so so b
implies a but a does not
uh give you b right in that in that case
the transitive property a equals b b
equals c so a equals c but not in this
case this i don't think there's a huge
amount of support for absolutely clear
cannabis leads to the use of harder
drugs uh i i don't think that that's
really been well well okay all right
guys we gotta end it there this has been
wonderful stacy to have you back on and
and this conversation's not going to end
here you know it all right uh marijuana
is with us to stay and it's going to
show up in all kinds of ways and you
don't just have insights on sports you
have insights into all facets of society
where marijuana could manifest and all
of its chemical derivatives so anyhow i
just want to thank you for being on star
talk again thanks for having me and gary
chuck always good to have you here as
much neil thank you always a pleasure
all right this has been star talk sports
edition all about cannabis in sports i'm
neil degrasse tyson as always bidding
you to keep looking up
[Music]
you